take 15 to 20 minutes off each day
and have a safe space that you go into a
safe space both physically in the
external and psycho emotionally in the
internal and go into that safe space and
get acquainted again right hi how am I
doing how how am I
who am I why am I everyone in your
audience has a driving force and
sometimes a good pause a good stop gets
you back in touch with that driving
force because the driving force when
it's activated has you in to act react
mode but when you actually get to settle
back down into the actual driving force
that's when you start to feel like oh
this is what I was this is why I started
what I'm doing there's a greater amount
of Joy there's a greater amount of
Happiness there's a greater amount of
friendliness having a daily practice is
the key to micro changing